if you're a fan of Steve Harvey and
you're looking for ways to hustle not
give up and multiply your efforts then
this video is for you
listen if success were easy you've heard
it a million times everybody would be
successful it requires a grit and a
toughness to be successful that's what
it came by you happiness dance don't
have no money
you go beep oh and see hide everything
if you apply your gift your god-given
gift that he gave you you have millions
already at your disposal
what's up believe nation its heaven my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see explode
out onto the world I started the mentor
me series to try to hang on people
who've done a lot more than us and
hopefully by spending a little bit more
time with them some of their beliefs
their way of thinking their mindset
seeps into us to help us become the best
version of ourselves so today we're
gonna learn from one of the best Steve
Harvey and some of his most
inspirational speeches mentor me Steve
okay here's a deal if you want to be
successful here's the thing you have to
do you have to jump there is no way
around you have to jump every successful
person has jumped you got to jump you
got to take a leap of faith
you got to dash off that cliff and you
got to jump out there as far as you can
now a lot of times you stand on the
cliff of life and you see other people
saw and by glide and down like a bird
and fly through the air you know they're
going over to the South of France you
see them on a boat somewhere you see
their family vacation in here and a
family vacation to that you see them
dressing like this you see him in New
York then you see them in London they
fine by you know why it's because the
impression on me but the only way to get
your passion to open so you could saw
you got the job now it is a problem
here's the problem my friends when you
jump I can assure you one thing you
listening I promise you this your
parachute will not hopefully right away
no that's the fatal flaw I promise you
your parachute will not open right away
you're gonna hit them sides in the rocks
you wanna tell your back out on your
cliff you gonna you don't cut yourself
you're gonna get born again you're gonna
get some tans and stuff like that but it
virtually parachute real home and you'll
be soft but here's the other caveat I'll
be teaching that's right in Italy if you
do not jump I promise you want that your
passion will never hold so you're safe
to another so you got to jump no matter
who you are no matter where you are in
life you can take the lid off of your
job and if you're wondering if you still
have the lid on in your life here are
some clues that's gonna let you know
that the lead is still on if you're not
excited about waking up in the morning
if you're sitting around bored out of
your mind if you got time to do
everything anybody asked you to do you
probably got to leave it on if when you
tell your dreams to all your friends it
makes sense to them you got your lid on
man
your dreams should be should not make
sense to everybody you gotta say
something to make people go how you
gonna do that that's when you got the
lid off and if I were you I'd do that I
take the lid off make sense you have to
get fluent in the language of success so
you speak it with ease surround yourself
with people who've accomplished their
dreams and immerse yourself in the
culture of achievement and before you
know it you're gonna be speaking the
life of your dreams into existence and
like I said before we each have a gift
but too many people miss out because
they refuse to sign the lease on their
gift you keep looking for it outside of
you stop sit with yourself what is it
that you do the absolute best with the
least amount of effort that's your gift
but if you are constantly looking
outside of yourself and you don't latch
on to your gift you will never find your
purpose if you want to succeed you must
commit to your own gift and embrace it
so when people try to figure out how to
make a million dollars they have no idea
how daunting that is because if you know
how to make a million dollars you go
make it tomorrow
position can't figure out how to a
million-dollar life do you go somewhere
and sit down that's the wrong approach
if you apply your gift your god-given
gift that he gave you you have millions
already at your disposal if you break it
down inch by inch anything's a cinch for
the 10 by 10 theory which is very simple
you don't need a million dollar do you
need a ten dollar idea
you need something that you do your gift
that God gave you to make $10 that's all
you got to be a no okay if it's cutting
hair cutting somebody's grass watching
somebody's car I don't care if it's
mowing somebody lawn I don't care if
it's the driving people today
destinations I don't care if it's
babysitting I don't care if it's baking
cookies up high you have some brain
somebody have you have something that
you can do so well that someone will
give you ten dollars for it right my
paper for me do this for me somebody
give you ten dollars for once they give
you ten dollars all you got to do is
whatever you did to get that ten do it
ten more times you now my friend I have
$100 you have one dollar and $100 simply
because you took a ten dollar idea and
you did it ten times well guess what if
you take that $100 that you made since
you've done it ten times and you do it
ten more times I Got News for you my
friend
you now have $1,000 $1,000 you make
$1,000 guess what all you got to do you
got to multiply that effort again do
whatever you did to do a thousand
dollars do it ten more times
my friend you now have ten thousand
dollars you got ten thousand dollars now
imagine if you was making the extra ten
thousand a month just imagine if you was
making an extra ten thousand dollars a
month that's 120 thousand dollars a year
but I Got News for you my friend
whatever you did whatever you did
whatever it took to make yourself ten
thousand dollars all you got to do is do
it ten more times
two more times my friend you now have
$100,000
I Got News for you now if you can make
$100,000
you're just a step away from being a
millionaire man because now you have a
few more people to help you out that
that you can do portions of what you do
so you can duplicate that effort and one
more time just one more time and do it
ten times man that sounds hard it is
hard but what else you got to do what
you gonna stop it two hundred thousand
all you got to do is duplicate your
efforts by ten you duplicate your
efforts by ten ten times 100,000 welcome
to the club my friends you are now a
millionaire congratulations you became a
millionaire with a $10 idea so stop
trying to stop bogging yourself down
trying to figure out how to make a
million do what you can do to make $10
and then do the ten by ten Theory
inch-by-inch anything since your
attitude determines your altitude if
you're a positive person positive things
happen to you if you're a negative
person negative things are going to
continue to happen for you if you can
put that in your scope this year just
change your attitude wake up and smile
how about just wake up and be grateful
it's just it's just common sense right
next thing especially after show like
today life is really 10% what happens to
you and 90% what you do about it
look everybody in this room everybody
watch it everybody got something they
got to deal with get to dealing with it
stop complaining about it complaining
about it only makes it stay present do
something about it so life is 10% what
happens to you is 90% what you do about
and finally don't give up when reaching
your dream is difficult listen if
success were easy you've heard it a
million times everybody would be
successful it requires a grit and a
toughness to be successful but I got
news for you it's something that all of
you have in you
now whatever you've been through
whatever that is guess what you still
here you know what that makes you a
pretty tough
it's gonna take more than an ocean to
become successful because once you get
this degree it's actually just gonna be
a piece of paper on the wall it's really
all this can be some people may give you
a job with it want the majority people
and tell you how much experience you
need so you got a hustle man gotta
hustle hustle and grind dig man got
fight no forgot a lot of dog in your man
to be rich and if you just want a job
get yourself a little job okay a nice
little life get a little house so
yourself a little minivan the station
wearing gonna ride your life are they
ain't nothin wrong with that but if you
really really really want to be balling
I've changed some people's lives get
yourself some real money hire people get
more than one stream of income company
gotta be a hustler man you gotta be a
hustler you all in the tech there's
money man money can buy you happiness
dance don't have no money tell you what
you go be poets he hide in a car for
three years we're struggling but I had a
dream and a vision and I got there also
I look back at myself sometime but I
think what advice would I tell that
young guy in college who was on the
verge of flunking out of that very same
College what would I tell myself well I
tell myself about forgiveness I remind
myself I would teach myself to forgive a
lot quicker including myself I held
myself to my own pain for a long time
because I kept rehashing those failures
over and over and over again and in
rehashing those failures it prevented me
from moving forward so I would tell that
20 year old guy back then be a little
bit more forgiving of yourself and a
whole lot more forgiving of other
people's to remember that Lord's Prayer
that your mama taught you forgive us our
trespasses as we forgive those who
trespass against us it would have made
my way a lot easier I would also tell
myself to slow down a little bit don't
go so fast what you're rushing fall life
is coming see every time you rush you
get ahead you missed some steps I've
missed a lot of steps in life but if you
noticed every time you missed a step in
life you gotta go back and get on that
step thank you guys so much for watching
I hope you enjoyed I'd love to know what
piece of advice what inspiring speech
had the biggest impact on you and why
leave it down the comments below I'm
really curious to see what you have to
say I also want to give a quick shout
out to Roenick from the Roenick classes
channel on youtube thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word I'm doing the review on your
channel I really appreciate the support
and I'm so glad you enjoyed the book I
would like to begin with the world by
Barry
personal it is a stay put behavior
reflects our view that the stock market
serves as a real location center at
which money is moved from active to
patients written by Warren Buffett so
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one where it is much love
I'll see you soon the most important
work ever if you had to think of one
word that's most important to you or
that sums you Apple
that would be collect a little beacon
pay believe nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details